today we're checking out two things the
Lenovo Mirage solo with daydream and the
Lenovo Mirage camera with daydream both
of these things are really excited and
they kind of work hand-in-hand this is a
VR 180 camera so I'm sure most of you
guys are very familiar with 360 cameras
where you can see everything you may
have seen some VR 180 where it's just
kind of like 180 degrees so it's not
entirely all around but it just gives
you sort of that extra little bit of
view so not only am I excited to try
this out but I'm also excited to trial
this headset because this is one of the
world's first stand-alone daydream
headsets don't need a PC you don't want
your phone you just need this headset
and everything is built in here a huge
thank you to Lenovo for sponsoring this
video and sending me these things to
check out I feel you could just keep
talking and I'm not even opening so
let's open and chat more about what's
inside smells like fresh technology I
just I don't know you guys if you've
ever opened up a new piece of tech it
just has the new tech smell it's like
the new car smell but oh my goodness
it's so lovely here is what the inside
of the box looks like here's the headset
one of the things that they were talking
about this features is it has a lot of
extra padding so it'll be very
comfortable that's also another huge
thing with some of the headsets if they
end up being heavy or not comfortable is
this supposed to be perfectly balanced
to show that if it is on your head it's
not gonna be wobbling different ways and
be uncomfortable we will test that out
and see if that is true it's
that adjusts it make it tighter or
looser on your head I've got an on
button and two volume buttons
we've got USBC I'm assuming this is all
of the things that they power it oh
you've got what looks to be some
headphones this also appears to be a
perfect length so it's not too long so
you can just plug this in and you don't
have too much extra cords or cables
hanging out so the little remote power
brick USBC cable okay I'm going to plug
in the headset charge it up for a bit
while I open up the camera so with this
it's pretty cool because you are
capturing content in Google's 180 format
so if you have ever seen 180 content on
YouTube then you're very familiar with
what I'm talking about I really like 180
because I feel like sometimes 360 it
gives people too much freedom so as a
creator this kind of limits you to
what's in front of you in to the sides
of you so you can transfer all of your
footage from this camera using the VR
180 app oh here it is oh it's so cool
I've never really played around much
with shooting 3d content and this does
shoot 3d so these are able to view it
into VR headset obviously lenovo it says
to use their Mirage solo headset but if
you do have another headset already you
can still view that content and if you
do view this content on your phone or
your computer it does convert it to 2d
so you will be able to actually enjoy
whatever it is that was shot let's see
what else is in here
charging bridge another USBC cable so
just two batteries in here
Oh a little carrying pouch
got a little magnet right here so you
can put your little charging cables in
here and put your camera in here this is
cool too because you can also livestream
which is pretty neat I've actually never
tried that either
Teru SBC micro SD card slot so basically
let this headset charge for just a few
minutes and I'm impatient we need to try
it out power button are you on oh you're
turning on I'm gonna kind of set it up
test it out and then hopefully any of
the content that I do shoot on the 180
camera I will put a separate link in the
description series and go check that out
also include some links to some other
creators who made videos with this
headset and the camera so you can check
those out as well okay so it's telling
me that I need this Wow VR is so freakin
cool another thing that's cool about
this headset is it uses a new Google
technology that allows you to have
positional tracking that normally was
only something that you could get using
a PC and a bunch of sensors but all of
that technology is built into this
headset and a lot of times those sensors
are to be able to tell where you are in
space in virtual reality so if you step
forward or you lean backwards go to the
side you duck you dodge this will be
able to detach all of that with no
sensors while that's updating we've got
our VR 180 camera what's cool about VR
180 is it's one of those things where
you feel like you're actually in the
room with a person or maybe not with a
person but wherever the camera happens
to be the best shooting practices when
you're shooting something in 180 is to
keep the camera still steady and don't
move it you don't have to move this
because it's already capturing the whole
world in front of you right below you
above you I push this to turn it on and
there's an app but I already downloaded
it's called the VR 180 app so it's
searching for my camera right now what
are you doing system update and so on
where's my oh my gosh
one of the things you should never do is
have a knife sitting directly in front
of you when you can't see what's in
front of you and you're looking for a
remote control so this is what the
camera is seeing right now and you can
see that it's kind of it like this
spherical setting so if you're moving
the camera up and down
you can tell that it's capturing this
whole world so obviously this is gonna
look way cooler inside of the headset
but for an example of what it would look
like not in a headset and if you have
Google cardboard that's also something
that you can use as well you can look
down at my desk and you can look you can
see what's over there surprise your
stuff so because I can't show you what
this looks like in headset me it's
scrolling around like that is kind of
what it would look like for you so this
is what it would look like first
yeah this is great
so everything is if fish' lee setup it's
complete everything is updated and one
of the things that i did mention earlier
about this being comfortable it
definitely is true because they feel
like everything like it doesn't feel
like it's too heavy on my head and this
also helps to be able to adjust so if I
need it to be tighter or looser it is
also something that I can do one of the
most difficult things about VR and
sharing it with other people is you are
inside of your own head but this is cool
because this has built-in chromecast so
you can basically cast what you're
seeing to a TV so if you have friends
over or family or whatever it is they
can enjoy what you're seeing so 36 to
you something that is so fascinating for
me because when you're a storyteller you
have to tell from all angles because you
can't really control where the user is
looking so with this oh god no don't not
you are absolutely terrifying oh I think
you guys are still over here I'm not
even sure okay this is something I don't
want to be watching by myself cuz I'm
scared oh okay oh now we're in the Play
Store
epic rollercoasters I like free fun I'll
install it oh boy
this is scary I'm not really a big
roller coaster fan to begin with
oh my goodness we're going up oh we're
going down oh we're going down we're go
look at me oh god I didn't roll my
trousers in real life
this is so intense so this is really
cool so I did a studio tour of like a
studios this was two years ago for Kubo
in the string this videos and we're
getting a behind-the-scenes 360 tour of
their studio to show you guys how they
made their new film
Kubo in the two streams I love this so I
was one of their animators right now
they can give you a little more detail
on how they made this because there is
just using the animation supervisor
these are our friends on the Internet oh
hi everybody
here's so much for watching if you would
like to get more information about the
Lenovo Marauders solo headset or the
Lenovo Mirage camera I will put all of
the links in the description below I
will also add some links to some other
Creators who made some videos featuring
these products if you want to watch
those you can do that and where where is
it oh that's right in the description
bigs are watching I always have so much
fun checking out new tech with you guys
whenever you guys think about this what
do you think of VR what do you think of
180 because yes I think this is
incredible as a creator it just gives us
sort of this whole new fun platform to
create content but what about you guys
as a viewer what are you guys think of
it and what is something that you would
most like to see shot in dr i look
forward to hearing all of your feedback
I will see you later bye
[Music]